let's take another call why don't we go
to I don't know let's go to 718 will
take a caller from the 718 area code
what's your name and where you're
calling from my name is binzhou I'm from
Queens New York awesome what's on your
mind today so lately I've heard from the
news that Trump has silenced several of
the of the federal registrations and and
I have just watched from YouTube that
said fascism has has already begun
uh-huh and what's your question job was
wondering and I was wiggling based on
days off this fact is it likely that he
that Trump would be easily get impeached
within within the next four years okay
now what was the first part of the
question that Trump has silenced who
does the Pope departments like the EPA
that USDA and the FDA oh okay well I'm
not sure I mean what he's done with the
EPA is required that they remove all
climate change-related stuff from the
website listen that's not an impeachable
offense I think it's a total misuse and
destruction of public trust when you
have taxpayer money going to climate
research which is on the EPA website and
then in comes from who believes climate
changes of hoax created by the Chinese
and says get rid of all that information
I think that's a huge insult to
taxpayers who paid for what is
scientific research but it's not an
impeachable offense you know to your
question of whether I think Trump will
get impeached or not I think that we've
all talked many times about perceived a
constitutional violations conflicts of
interest that Trump is involved in etc I
actually don't know that if Trump gets
in teach that it's going to be because
of something like that I believe that as
a guy who came in with thirty-seven
percent approval on day one if Trump's
approval
doesn't go up but rather goes down and
stays down I believe you will start to
see establishment Republicans tried it
to to get Trump out and what mechanism
they will use I don't know but it's
going to be a disaster for Republicans
in 2018 if Trump's approval instead of
going up goes into the 20s or even the
low 30 so that that's my thought on that
I don't know if that makes sense to uh
well well well I'm going to well
according to a young turks video uh-huh
even even even the host even though C&K
also says that says that he will start
he would start state Goulding and that's
when we go into danger zone yes
scapegoat I'm sure whatever junk said I
would love to hear it I didn't hear it
but I think scapegoating Trump has
already been scapegoating everybody but
himself it's because of the media that
people thought no one went to the
inauguration it's because of the media
that there's a perceived war with Intel
Trump will scapegoat you know
undocumented immigrants anybody he can I
appreciate the call really really great
to hear from callers in Queens that's
all the time we have today we don't have
time for more calls today Pat thanks to
everybody who called we will take calls
again and we will make calls great again
that I can promise you today david
pakman.com slash membership use that
coupon code i voted 17 for a major
orange president discount off of
membership